WHAT ARE YOU TRYING TO DO?!
CHOKE ME WITH BACTERIA?!
That glass of water you're drinking probably
contains 10 million bacteria.
Yep.
That's a lot.
Researchers at Lund University in Sweden revealed
exactly how many bacteria is living in the
pipes that bring you drinking water.
According to their paper in Applied Microbiology
and Water Resources, our drinking water has
eighty thousand bacteria per MILLILITER, and
a couple thousand more bacteria species in
the pipes themselves!
Using flow cytometry, a laser-based system,
scientists counted what was previously uncountable:
every tiny particle flowing through our water
pipes.
Then using DNA sequencing, they uncovered
a huge diversity of bacteria lurking behind
our faucets.
BUT DON'T FREAK OUT.
This is completely normal!
This is like turning on the lights in a dark
room.
We knew stuff was going on around us, but
didn't know exactly what was involved.
For example, in a 2013 issue of Water Science
and Technology, researchers isolated four
types of microorganisms commonly found in
drinking water: Sphingobium, Xenophilus, Methylobacterium,
and Rhodococcus.
These are mostly harmless genuses of bacteria
found in soil, on leaves and in lakes.
How'd it get from the Yukon to your glass?
Naturally.
Drinking water is fed by snow and rain which
streams down mountainsides to rivers where
it's pumped, diverted or dammed to provide
a supply of drinking water.
Bacteria hitches a ride on that trip too,
all the way to your parched throat and beyond.
The water is filtered between the lake and
your home though.
Water treatment plants use increasingly finer
meshes, sands, settling and aeration tanks
to filter out particles, and often add chlorine,
or use ultraviolet light to kill any microorganisms.
The city of Hong Kong created a helpful graphic
to show how they add Alum, Lime, Chlorine,
and polyelectrolytes, to clean and clarify
their water before sending it on to their
citizens.
They even add a bit of fluoride for dental
hygiene.
Once out of the treatment plant though, the
water is exposed to bacteria once again…
in the pipes.
When left to it's own devices in an aqueous
environment, bacteria will form what's called
a biofilm.
Biofilms are like plaque on your teeth, or
kombucha… only less… no, about equally
gross.
And our water systems are FILLED with them.
But again, don't freak out, think of these
films of bacteria like our gut microbiota,
most are good!
Researchers in the International Journal of
Environmental Health said biofilms "represent
the most successful form of life."
Though gross looking, they're generally not
harmful; some are even healthful!
In nature, they provide self-cleaning potential
for soils, sediments and water, but in our
pipes biofilms may be trapping dangerous pathogens
before they get to you!
Government agencies at every level test municipal
water supplies in order to keep citizens safe.
No doubt this is partly why the United Nations'
Global Drinking Water Quality Index rates
the US as having some of the best water in
the world.
But trying to make our systems 100-percent
"clean" -- that is bacteria free -- might
be damaging!
According to Professor Catherine Biggs at
the University of Sheffield, "The way we currently
maintain clean water supplies is a little
like using antibiotics without knowing what
infection we're treating," it works, but just
like in our gut, we might be harming the good
organisms along with the bad.
We don't want to kill ALL bacteria in our
water, but as techniques improve, we can filter
out the bad bacteria, and leave the biofilms
to help out.
We know you love watching online, but we’re
excited to announce DNews is now on Science
channel!
We'll be sharing a minute of the best in science
in between awesome programming.
So check us out as Science Presents DNews
at 9!
Every weeknight, Monday through Friday, and
use your twitter to let them know if you want
more!
Does the discovery of water bacteria put you
off tap water?
It SHOULDN'T…